ils ont parlé un petit peu de musique
maintenant avec un duo assez étonnant à
première vue france gall et elton john
pour ceux qui connaissent mal
elton john s'agit d'un pianiste noirs
américains équipe assez facilement
reconnaissable grâce à grande casquette
il est pas noir dit oui les premières et
il n assez longue casquette c'est
lui-même qui a téléphoné à france gall
un jour parce qu'ils avaient envie
d'enregistrer un disque avec elle alors
il lui a téléphoné et ça va donner un
disque pour la première fois en france
et aux états unis
c'est que c'est pas très habituel de
voir des disques qui marche en france de
france aux alliés depuis la fayette nous
avions un peu perdu l'habitude d'être
sollicités depuis le territoire
américain heureusement elton john cet
anglais consacré aux états unis qui se
sent très européen et qui aime beaucoup
la france et sa culture a décidé cet été
de chanter en français avec france gall
résultat ce duo qui permettra peut-être
d'entamer le protectionnisme rigoureux
qui sévit du moins en matière de chanson
d'expression française
chez nos voisins d'outre-atlantique
je te donne cet espoir âgé
kita
le faire
il
jeudi temps
c'est déjà compliqué
michel berger le mari de france calle a
bien sûr participé à l'élaboration de ce
45 tours qui consacre une alliance
franco britannique inattendue qui
espérons le aura moins de déboires que
le concorde
m
par le plein de vie